I'll just give you two brief examples
from the from the interface of
psychology
neuroscience that our new germane to the
discussion we had last hour but free
will or volition or whatever we're now
calling it 'american senses ears and a
conscious experience and one assistive
you know point out something from brain
science and psychology about the lipid
studies which get a lot of air time and
this this relationship between one when
something happens in your head you're
now ostensibly conscious perception of
that and those experiments when we think
about them or talk about them informally
or agus it makes a presupposition that
there's an arrow of time and there is an
arrow of time okay and if they air it so
it makes a present position for us back
in psychology that the arrow of time is
something new Tony like absolute true
mathematical time of itself and by its
own nature flows equably without
relation to anything external and um and
we also assume as a presupposition the
behavior cannot be uncaused so we have
maken relatively we assume that at the
look that they're the local temporal
order of events matters I think we can
probably agree on that but it turns out
that depends on what local is so local
isn't just it doesn't follow from from
something like the Newtonian arrow
button so from a brain science know
psychology point of view time just isn't
like so it's more like a string of beats
or a series of little temporal islands
and those little islands have a certain
size and so for instance one size for
which we have really a huge amount of
evidence it's an experimental researches
and the order of a quarter of a second
so it's so there is an arrow over all
but that arrow is actually a series of
little chunks and the chunk size is
pretty coarse its coarse grained and it
turns out that within that chunk you can
you don't actually have to respect the
order things get even worse as an
example I was just done so there's so
one
so there's a big let's say a big chain
of pearls where the pearls are really
fat big let's say a quarter of a second
big there's another chain in your ring
where they the pearls are really rather
small let's say on the order of 50
milliseconds or something like that
those are too strikingly different sizes
of template's experience and it's within
that that local temporal order doesn't
even have to be respected at all so you
can actually change the order of things
and pay no price perceptually which is
kind of bizarre you have the same
content absolutely so let me give you a
bear I'll give actually that I just
spoke a very concrete example suppose
you I give you we listening to each
other here and I take the sentence I
record it and I chop it up I just take
the file you can do it actually right
now in your lap but I chopped up the
file and I take each slice and I flip it
backwards all right so if I take the
whole sentence and I flip it backwards
like and you could understand anything
as you make the slices smaller and
smaller there is a slice size at which
you pay no perceptual price and your
judgments are the same and it turns out
to be roughly 60 milliseconds or
something like that
that's pretty interesting so now I think
at the course grand scale the arrow of
time is going and you predict the
direction that we need otherwise things
we're really screwed but at the local
scale it's actually something quite
different that's happening from the
perspective of the perceptual apparatus
and the neurophysiological foundations
of how you do that and so there are
these so that sort of undermines the
most straightforward interpretations of
a little bit of experiment too because
you actually chunk things into much
coarser grain before that you know as
you attribute to conscious it doesn't
centers on the claim that we should be a
very doubtful about the confident
assertions that we make on the basis of
corner of conscious introspection in
fact it reinforces it that's fine
okay but it's very compatible with the
idea that what we call consciousness is
a higher level of urgent phenomenon sort
of different ways of rearranging
microscopic pieces I think so I think
it's it's very bizarre it's also
compatible with the claim that all
Shakespeare's plays were written by Ben
Jonson I don't know where where did this
emergentism come well because I mean
yeah I think we should return to that
but beyond this point and just a second
example and I guess I was moved by an
Stevens point of that there surely is a
causal chain of things and some of them
are conscious as you decided to come
here and visit your granddaughter
whatever it was and so now you're and um
so we are we know we also know that very
little actually enters into our
conscious experience that we that that
makes a difference in the stuff we
decide right so take so here's a you
know an experimental example that's you
know straightforward and kind of cool
take the cocktail party stuff so we're
you know I'm listening to here almost
concurrently let's say Dan and Steve or
something like that time and I'm able to
select one or the other conversation so
I can pick that out using something
called attention who knows how that
works and selective attention I can
attend to one of the streams at a party
right so there's there's a big mess you
guys er he wasn't attending
nidana yes right so I can select so
there's concurrent information I can
select one stream over another now I
happen to know that both are encoded I
mean I can show you that experimentally
so both actually are encoded at the
perceptual systems so I can also show
you is that the information and the
unattended stream
you can't which you cannot report to
meudon anything that was said there
actually influences in a systematic
predictable principled way decisions
that you make later for instance about
what words you recognize or something
that would second describe that yes
right so it's just so and now does that
information play a causal role in how
you made subsequent decisions I'd say
yes because like because I rigged it
that way I can do the experiments I put
all the words in the way that you know
subsequently they influence it so I
guess I'm nervous or squeamish about the
importance of the conscious access to
the to the decision making that you seem
to require at the end at the end of your
discussion because so much of it is I
mean you're moving concepts around in
your head because that movement of the
concepts and arranging them until you
come to decision uncaused I think I know
what Alex was getting at with the Venn
Johnson comment maybe I now have the
response so when I when I said in
response to David that it's compatible
with this emergent idea what I I guess
was implicitly saying is it's obvious
that it that that doesn't seem
compatible with the idea that
consciousness is fundamental but it also
doesn't seem incompatible incompatible
with the idea that it's emerging so I
think that this does it doesn't it's not
evidence for consciousness being
emergent just like it's not evidence for
Ben Johnson or Shakespeare's authorship
but it does help way the if those two
options are what you're considering I
think that it pushes the balance down a
little bit if there's the third option
you're considering that we shouldn't
just be talking about consciousness at
all then sure everything David is saying
certainly kids
do that and the experiment that Dan just
gave us it's profound evidence that we
cannot ignore consciousness at all
definitely sometimes has a causal well
good shorten I could be happy with that
yeah the question that I'm interested in
is what is consciousness consistent what
is its function these are not questions
that we have much of a handle on at all
what we do know are already from from a
lot of the experimentation including
what you've just described is that
consciousness systematically misleads us
as an epistemic source
you